yeah welcome to this video I'm a bit
late here i made the slight mistake in
the setup but now it's working and
hopefully recording just fine get a car
calm and someone asked me why don't you
play the classical on I do but I'd like
to I'd like to try this um this line
because I think it's quite fascinating
and it leads to I'm quite interesting
games so we have this c3 line again and
now queen bee three years a bit of a bit
of a snoozer hmm do I need to exchange
Queens I mean it's not like this is
terrible to do so do I have other ideas
yeah spending back Asia's here for
nothing let's just get on with with
moves drop the night here I could have
taken but and then I don't know I don't
want to improve his pawn structure of
course this is really an improvement
giving him the double phone so Queenie
phone should be three mmm nice maybe
playing Bishop d3
see if I have not defiled is not a big
problem if i move the night be seven is
hanging this is tricky hmm yup is going
to play Bishop to d3 this is really not
easy maybe I should try Bishop f5 can i
play Bishop f5 that's if it sees the c5
keep trying to annoy him a bit on on the
jeep on
the screen on e4 is a slightly
problematic okay maybe quit if I for
something this looks like I'm i really
miss played this opening it looks very
very disjointed to all this lots of
Queen moves and and plants that are not
really connected with each other I can I
can I can go back play Bishop f5 or
queen here let's go back push-up f5 for
this is really bad game i'm in bed bed
by black bad by black and song sounds
like an ac/dc song not back in black but
bed bed public okay Bishop f5 maybe if I
can get this in and I'm not completely
destroyed after c5 and b7 is gone oh
this is curious why would you do that
the sugar 5 takes takes c5 ID 5 mm okay
I need to I need of awesome that's it's
no use I saw that I'm giving the spawn
but I hope that I have fun good piece
coordination king of one is really weird
yeah my thought process was ok his King
is it's really bad even even a queen
trade isn't so so clear what Quincy aid
come on rook c8 looks very shaky as well
I need to tell you I need to cover c6
anyway yeah this is some an extra porn
obviously for white but not technically
I'm no it's not it's not impossible what
what can go before he doesn't at the
moment he doesn't look see for him
brooksy form
maybe a five Bishop see several nights
are clean but I'm hanging on yeah this
was really a terrible opening play
I especially move the Queen so often
yeah okay but how is going to did I fall
asleep here spend some time doing
nothing yeah okay a five puts it on the
square where is under on that tag why I
didn't even see that nice okay let's
hope but it's not such a big deal and I
get the porn back maybe at the end of
the day porn as helpful well
I wonder if you for another scope I need
to be quickly anyway maybe if he takes
and allows me to play effort if other am
getting really come to play I can play
d4 for example G for some we've been put
in a good mood and now down to 30
something seconds
now the 8th porn and the Jeep one is
hanging it's at least something but of
course I'm I'm I busted so anyway to to
get to those pawns back off at the
airport but it's a pretty good pawn
I can take in to take h5 yep this is uh
this is gone yeah jack yeah can sign
that this was just just bad opening play
yeah I don't know just probably i'm
moving the Queen a bit to be too often
hear ya i can i can take it i'll be
three but i don't like to improve his
structure this it's not what i would
like to do yall 97 maybe i should just
take I don't know but this isn't so bad
I think maybe this was some was really
really bad Queen to h5 first Queen to h5
I don't know I'm inventing a head as i
go along a I don't know really what is
plenty a queen bee three I just forgot
yeah thanks for watching